what's the famous quote where it says
men wear married women hoping that they
will never change and that Women Marry
men hoping that they will change and
then invariably they'll both be
disappointed I think it's very it goes
It goes men marry women hoping they
don't change and they do women marry men
hoping they change and they don't right
yeah and they both end up disappointed
so I think if you establish what you
were just talking about up front Hey
listen I'm not that nine to five guy
that's six o'clock dinner thing every
night I'm just shooting a freaking video
by six o'clock I might not even be home
till eight so like this is the guy
you're going to marry are you
comfortable with that yeah because I
don't seven years down the road I want
to be like why are you never home it's
like I told you that up front
[Music]
[Applause]